hey and welcome special meteor hit the
atmosphere of the earth a long time ago
meteor fell in pieces and it's crystals
were lost our grandfather found two of
those crystals and discovered that they
had special effects on horses
I didn t come to that conclusion the
crystals gave special abilities to
verses he said but no one believed him
the scholars laughed at him and expelled
him
he gave those two crystals to us hoping
that me would be able to be a nice his
dreams choose a player we have a great
cha o
gone cha I'll be gone cha here we are in
the magical world yes oh now it's
snowing raining what am i doing
it's this game play um enter in my
stable place oh this game is wonderful
name your horse
Marcia beautiful oh look it's my [ __ ] oh
it's so cute
oh yes I shall nourish you you need to
collect five meteor crystals or [ __ ] you
Gunther
hey what an upgrade fine okay we
upgraded this table well now we enter
alright well my [ __ ] is still there then
my caucus grow my [ __ ] it grew into
unicorn amazing
now can we shop stuff for my [ __ ] um
feather I mean I don't see why not
Wow of course of course
10 out of 10 bronies recommend this game
fabulous for fabulous
soundcheck man Oh Oh break it down my
[ __ ] here we go son gameplay get ready
what do I do good job
okay my horse my horse is mentally
challenged I think I did something there
I don't [ __ ] understand it's just for
video games this while I was fun I
really enjoyed that one
okay let's try sledge bowling then [ __ ]
it out you're not you're not telling me
to do anything this was a click it
what how did I do that oh my god
fabulous fabulous fabulous here please
please game of the air game of the air
[ __ ] beautiful
no my [ __ ] did the [ __ ] so now I
pimped out my horse it's time to race uh
there's only one other player who owns
this game and it's Brad Brad
are you ready to race I've never been
more ready um I'm so glad to actually
have a second player players I've been
playing this game competitively for
years but only against myself so okay do
you know how to actually go into a race
okay how about the Arctic Road the
octave road click on that one yeah
waiting for players okay oh oh my god
were the only people we are literally
the only people that only Oh God
Oh what the [ __ ] are these whoa which
one is you uh-oh there you are you at
the channel inland yeah I look like
ridin ridin which one of you I have no
idea which I'm in the back there should
be a text over my a my name I continue
I'm too far ahead
um yeah I'm just waiting just wait I'll
slow down for okay thank you a card
I literally caught my husband together
slow down there you are I see you okay
there you go
yeah you look like a little pageant
queen that thank you
yeah that's how I like it we need to
like the winner someone needs to do
something needs to happen okay I don't
know what the winner is allowed to
uninstall the game the loser has to play
every day keep living up your euro
unicorn I don't know what happened like
you overtook me and yeah it's over it de
motivated my horse so much that I'm
Joyce nice to kill itself we are the
only two people that are in this game we
only
the only two people I actually think
like that was a joke and I think it
might be trade ok underwater cave how
about that that looks pretty cool yeah
underwater cave it is oh wow look at you
where am I where are you you had you've
got the little pink hat on now yeah so
I'm the one with the enormous [ __ ]
crab on my back oh this is trippy as
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah yes no no what the
[ __ ] is that crab stupid crab shoehorn I
don't know what the shoe one does it
didn't do [ __ ] what's the most intense
gameplay there's so much at stake
I think I'm oh no no no no no no what is
that a tenth a tenth of a second you won
bin all right best two out of three
because you won one and I won one out of
the two yeah that makes sense
I'm okay with this why am i winning I
think I'm winning winning not on my
screen you're lost
damnit you passed me how do you get so
much speed I'm wrecking I'm winning [ __ ]
yeah
I've told you a thousand times it's the
crash [ __ ] you and your crab I got the
sickest speed ever now and I would have
what the [ __ ] can and crap yeah come on
crab see ya no see you know coming out
you know [ __ ] you I got a la speed a la
speed this is not good oh my god I'm
like come on ah oh man I got an
achievement star yes I think I'm even
gonna make it to the finish line and
we're not even gonna wait for you I came
last if you are wondering okay dead last
maybe you need to you probably need to
spend more money on the game alright so
I'm ready to uninstall thank you it's
been a it's been a good uh right fine
I'm gonna drop a hundred dollars on the
game alright and play it every day for
the rest of my life as as that was my
penance I need to burn it the question
is how do you remove it from time itself
oh that's not possible